l'association avec véronique proulx pdg
de manufacturiers et exportateurs du
québec bonsoir enfin le ministre morneau
parle de considérer des mesures fiscales
dit qu'on est dans une bonne position
pour agir faire des choses pour les
entreprises est ce que ça vous rassure
en fait on est heureux d'entendre qu'il
reconnaît qu'il ya une problématique que
le gouvernement semble être en bonne
posture pour réagir
de notre côté c'est clair qu'on commence
à ressentir l'impact du corps à nos
virus alors les entreprises sont encore
en train de gérer l'effet du blocage
ferroviaire se rajoutent les faits du
qoran au virus c'est sûr que la
situation est complexe pour les
manufacturiers ils le gèrent au
quotidien pour réussir à reprendre un
déçu ça ressemble à quoi l'impact du
coup renault virus en ce moment pour
vous alors plusieurs entreprises
manufacturières sa provision de la chine
bien sûr en produits finis en composant
tard matières premières il ya des
retards de livraisons importants on
parle de certains fournisseurs qui ont
fermé leurs usines en chine pendant un
mois ou qui sont encore fermées alors
les entreprises n'arrivent pas toujours
à trouver des alternatives
alors c'est la même bien sûr d'aider
retard un retard de livraisons retardées
fabrication des pénalités qui sont
associés donc la situation évolue les
entreprises tentent de mettre en place
des plans de contingence mais c'est pas
simple non ce sont elles prêtes les
entreprises à faire face à cette crise
là alors ce n'était pas attendu à ce
qu'elles seront prêtes à y faire face
vraiment je faisais les entreprises les
gèrent au quotidien parce que
présentement au niveau logistique c'est
excessivement complexe et c'est là où
ils mettent leur temps et qu'ils
investissent énormément temps pour
trouver des solutions
est ce qu'elles sont prêtes j'ai envie
de dire non parce que c'était inattendu
c'est pas quelque chose qui était prévu
et il ya beaucoup d'incertitudes
présentement et d'un secteur
manufacturier est ce que c'est possible
de faire du télétravail par exemple
c'est très difficile jeu lorsqu'on parle
d'une chaîne de montage surtout dans un
contexte de pénurie de main d'oeuvre au
québec très difficile d'être capable
d'assurer la fabrication il est le bon
fonctionnement de son usine cissé en a
des gens qui sont absentes donc si des
gens doivent s'absenter ou s'il faut
mettre en quarantaine par exemple toute
une usine où toute une partie des
travailleurs
ben vous avez besoin simplement d'une
compensation y'a pas moi n'y ait de
travailler
romain n'est pas tellement d'alternative
autre solution et c'est pourquoi on
demande au gouvernement fédéral de
mettre en place un support financier
pour aider les entreprises qui seront
affectés parce qu'éventuellement c'est
ça se poursuit plusieurs d'entre elles
seront gravement touché deux types de
supports financiers
alors on a sondé nos membres ya des
mesures qui ressorte la première bien
sûr c'est des subventions les
entreprises la dernière chose dont elles
veulent c'est de la dette alors souvent
dans les cas où des cas similaires le
gouvernement fédéral et provincial ont
mis en place des programmes de prêts
pour aider les entreprises qui étaient
en difficulté financière une entreprise
qui est en difficulté financière la
dernière chose qu'elle veut c'est la
dette additionnel donc on parle de
mesures de programmes de subventions ou
ça fait des mesures fiscales comme la
réduction de la taxe sur la masse
salariale qui prêtent une mesure ciblée
annoncé au budget qui pourrait couvrir
par exemple la période pendant laquelle
les entreprises sont affectés ou les
entreprises qui démontrent un impact
significatif monsieur morneau a évoqué
dans l'entrevue la possibilité de
maintenir l'accès au crédit le crédit
pour les entreprises et monsieur trump
aux etats unis aujourd'hui a annoncé des
prêts qu'on pourrait faire à des pme à
plus faible taux oui donc on sent que
les gouvernements sont pas
nécessairement tout près de la
subvention qui sont prêts à aider mais
pas jusqu'à donner complètement d'argent
et malheureusement c'est pas une serre
masquer le plus dutil dans ce contexte
là si je permets de faire le parallèle
avec les tarifs qui avait eu sur l'acier
l'aluminium
lorsque le gouvernement américain taxer
les entreprises canadiennes le
gouvernement canadien avait mis en place
des prêts à faible intérêt pour les
entreprises peu d'entre elles avaient
appliqué
encore une fois lorsqu'elle sens
difficultés financières elles ne veulent
pas de la dette elle vint le support
elles veulent avoir plus d'oxygène
elle veut être capable de passer au
travers donc une mesure fiscale comme la
réduction de la taxe sur la masse
salariale permettrait d'alléger le
fardeau fiscal des entreprises est passé
au travers la crise est-ce que vous avez
un premier bilan des effets des dommages
des blocages ferroviaire sur l'industrie
manufacturière
oui absolument là on a fait un sondage
auprès nos membres
et ce qui nous a permis de voir que 50%
des manufacturiers connaissent
on connaît des difficultés financières
importantes ont des pénalités
financières importantes à cause de lock
up absolument alors on parle de 25000 à
50 mails par jour de frais additionnels
en moyenne pour les entreprises
manufacturières pour certaines d'entre
elles on parle de frais qui se cumulent
au delà des millions de dollars donc
impact financier à court terme actuel
est très important est ce que dans le
budget de mardi du gouvernement du
québec vous vous attendez à des annonces
ciblées pour vous en fait on s'attend on
souhaite qu'elle et demande que l'on
avait formulé soit mise en place parce
que ce sont des mesures qui visent à
stimuler l'investissement à réduire le
fardeau fiscal des entreprises
et advenant que le budget soit favorable
à nos demandes
ça permettrait aux entreprises de passer
au travers la crise plus facilement cela
dit les blocages ferroviaires sont
terminés oui est ce que la crise des
blocages ferroviaire pour le secteur
manufacturier quelque chose de terminer
aussi qui fait partie du passé pour tout
à fait dans le sens où ça va prendre
encore un 4 à 6 semaines peut-être deux
mois avant de récupérer le retard au
niveau logistique alors l'impact les
entreprises vont le ressentira encore
pendant quelques temps on a des membres
qui ont perdu des contrats par exemple
auprès de clients américains ce ne sont
pas des contrats qui vont pouvoir
récupérer à court terme donc on en a
encore pour un bon bout de temps à
ressentir ses effets là et que renault
virus mais s'ajoute encore une fois sur
le fardeau des entreprises
manufacturières véronique trouve merci
beaucoup pour cet entretien ce soir